hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday Monday Monday
August 7th
2023. what's going on how are you
how are you I am uh I'm on vacation
I'm winding down my vacation I'll get
one more day of vacation and then it's
back to the black and white
um
but I had an amazing time
me and my family have been staying down
here in Martha's Vineyard
um there's no wine on Martha's Vineyard
if some white dude a long time ago had a
daughter or a wife named Martha and he
named the island after her
and probably did not check in on the
people that were already living there
[Laughter]
either the people that were originally
there or the people that killed the
people that were there or re-educated
them to their Methodist ways whatever
the [__] happened over there I don't
know but all I know is I came by three
400 years later and I had a lovely time
um
been having a lovely time uh I will tell
you this if you've never been to
Martha's Vineyard you got to check it
out man it's absolutely gorgeous
they shot Jaws here
way back in 74 came out in the 1975 I
believe and began the summer blockbuster
craze
you can thank Jaws
right that [__] movie why every
summer Tom Cruise saves us from
something
no Jaws no Tom Cruise Tom Cruise would
have been doing like [__]
I don't know what he would have been
doing
you've been doing a western or some [__]
um
yeah I believe that was the first one
that just caused this absolute which
isn't is nuts to me because I would
think that you know there was big hit
movies
before then you would think that there
would be lines down the street but I
think this was the one that was sort of
almost like a pop song
where it just appealed to everybody and
everybody wanted to go see it and you
know and then of course Star Wars a
couple years later so anyway it was shot
down there
and uh there's a lot of ice cream
a lot of ice cream to be had
hey
uh
uh what else a lot of a lot of people
eating ice cream down there I will say
that I've no I've never seen so much
[__] ice cream consumed in my life
like every five in my life every like
five feet there was another place to get
ice cream and there was a bunch of
people standing outside not saying
anything [__] eating ice cream
eating ice cream and I did not I didn't
get ice cream once when I was there I
was like I'm not doing that I am not
going to be waddling down the street in
a pair of [__] salmon colored shorts
open-toed sandals being just a yet
another person waddling down the street
um
actually I'm lying there weren't that
many fat Fox on the island
I don't think there was you know they
couldn't have made the ferry ride over
you know they'd have to hang them off
the side
um
anyway
and while I was on the island I did the
most incredible
um
touristy thing I've ever done in my life
all right
wait I
yeah wait a second before I get going I
on like one of the nights I was out
there I popped in and did a stand-up
show in uh Oaks Bluff or OB
as the locals call it
um at the Strand Theater I want to say
uh Steve Capas runs that thing and I got
to work with uh
Damon Williams who I had not seen in
Forever
was a fantastic crowd I went up you know
tried out a few new things did some
stuff that worked and I had I had a
great time
and then you leave and they got this
[__] somebody goes you gotta go you
got to go to like uh back door Donuts
I'm like what's back door don't it's
like oh you know after that [__] you
know
bacon all day you know they sell Donuts
out the back
you know cash only out the back but Baba
buying all this [__] now I know what you
guys saying like Bill why are you
ratting these guys out I'm not ratting
anybody out there was a [__] line
like nine miles long so you feel like
you're doing some you know prohibition
[__] like you're going into like a donut
Speak Easy but you're not
it's like you don't have to know a
password they literally have like a lion
out the back like you're at [__]
Disneyland and uh
you know I had been laying off this I
was just like I don't eat desserts I
don't eat desserts and everybody's like
you got to get the apple fritter you got
to get it's like hey man
I don't have to [__] do anything but
you know I'm gonna
the way you guys were all lined up here
like [__] sugar zombies
so I ordered one and I gotta tell you
lived up to the hype I had like four
bites of that thing the thing was
gigantic you could split it between
three adults no problem or if you want
early onset diabetes you just wolf it
down yourself you know with another
little donut Chase or whatever I had the
thing backdoor Donuts
unbelievable midnight tacos ain't there
fantastic
where else did I go
I can't remember the names if there's
one place I went I got oysters like
twice
in uh J Edgar Hoover town
anyway
I wrote a bicycle every [__] day
I do this giant loop I went around and
then I was getting coffee at this place
uh
uh behind the bookstore a lot of [__]
covert [__] that's not too covert you
know backdoor Donuts
uh [__] uh you know behind the
bookstore coffee
down low brothers from Atlanta you know
they got all kinds of like just
seemingly you know
clandestine [__] but it's kind of all
out in the open anyway
so I get my coffee there I would get I'd
get the [__] papers the papers every
morning I ride the bike into town I get
myself a quartado right and I would
[__] get the globe in The Herald and
I would just sit there like an old man
sipping coffee and I would read the
paper and then I'd get back on my bike
and I would ride home
did that every day it was like a 40
minute total ride
and uh you know kept the pounds off
for the most part you know I maybe
gained a few but like uh whatever I'm
gonna be back in LA tomorrow I'll hit
the gym
back on the elliptical you know I think
I maintained which is pretty good to be
away for like six seven days is pretty
good but anyway let's let's get to the
deal so we were staying in this little
house right
and I keep seeing like these Snoopy
biplanes the Snoopy biplane like flying
by Red Baron looking thing
and the first day I saw it I was just
going like wow look at that thing man I
heard those things only cruise at like
60 70 knots or something like that like
that's top speed and they're da da da da
and all this these ideas that I had I
was like man I've always wanted to ride
one of those
and then you know like an hour later I
see the guy going by again I'm like oh
that guy's flying for a while and then I
just started noticing like every like
half hour or something this red biplane
would go over my head and I'm like
they're giving tours there's no [__]
way there's not tours so he found out
there's there was an airport
a couple miles away with a grass Runway
katama or some [__] like that airport
little breakfast place there evidently
they had a good lobster roll I did not
partake I don't eat lobster
all right until they learn how to kill
those [__] things before they drop
them in boiling water I don't know why
they can't knock them out they can't
give them a little anesthetic why do you
have to boil it alive
like we're trying to convert its
religion
you know
um
anyway
so I go over there and I say I say to
the woman over there I said hey you guys
can I get a ride in that thing and there
was two of them they go yeah
it's like all right what's the deal she
goes what's over there on the sign right
so they had like you know these four
different trips you could take one of
them
was like an entire hour around the whole
island so I'm like I want to do that
so she's like fine I go can I do that
tomorrow she goes all right she goes
yeah she goes oh you can do it in like
in a half hour we have an opening
and I was like even better I'll do that
all right so I went in I got coffee
you know I come back out
and she goes all right he's going to be
landing soon they had two of them going
right and she says to me
you know for an extra 120 bucks or
something like that you want to get the
acrobatic package and I'm like what's
that he goes uh you know they do like a
series of seven acrobatic moves like
loop-de-loops and dive bomb and twisty
turnies and
that [__] I was like yeah
I'm gonna do that
I've always wanted to do a [__] Loop
in an airplane better yet even in a
biplane so they're like yeah fine
so she goes sign the waiver and now I'm
thinking like what am I doing
I got two young kids and I'm fine this
[__] guy does this all the time he
must right then they gave me a parachute
and I'm like all right what's the deal
here
like do I gotta pull this thing she goes
no I go so it's like a static line right
because I've done that I did a long time
ago in Pepperell Massachusetts
let me tell you guys about that
19 years old one day course Arc one
thousand two one thousand three one
thousand look if nothing look reach pull
I still remember that you're looking for
your shoot if it ain't there you have to
look down to the red thing or else
should be like fumbling for it like an
old man trying to find his glasses you
got to look for the red handle and then
you [__] pull it so it was a one day
course I guess in the Army it's like oh
it's like a week before they let you
even
do it you know but these people were
just like hey you know in fact there's
two guys in my class that would join in
the Army and wanted to be paratroopers
and wanted to get one jump out of the
way so anyway
this is a one day course they send you a
video you watch like a VHS tape this
back in 87 summer of 87. you watched the
VHS tape of uh you know
whatever all the fun you have skydiving
and all that [__] and then the end this
lure just comes on going you know if you
die you can't sue us and everybody's
laughing nervously so anyway so we go to
do it
and uh I remember this this bigger woman
you know you jump it was sit in the door
get out go Arc one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand look if
nothing looked reach pull right
so she does that but when you put one
and then they had a radio and they
talked you down
they just had a spotter and they would
just [__] talk it down and when they
told you to pull the toggles you had to
pull it all the way down to your knee
all right but you know she was a bigger
girl she had some ads and tired she was
only getting it down to her waist and I
think with her weight too like she was
dropping faster whatever she ended up
Landing across the street in a pile of
loom
um
and dislocated her knee so that was a
bummer so then I went up there and you
know me I don't pay attention right
and uh the guy were up there and the
guy's going sit in the door and I'm like
what he's like sit in the door I thought
he said close the door so I'm going to
close it he's just sitting there smiling
at me I remember the guy was a jerk off
like he was enjoying like thinking that
I was freaking out I couldn't hear what
he was saying he was like sit in the
door I was like oh all right so I sit in
the door he goes get out I got out you
know
it's just like Fandango they did the
same thing you get on I'm actually
acting now you get on one foot you
[__] hang on like the the the wing
was over the fuselage and you're hanging
on to the basically the support thing
right
and uh
he slaps you on the shoulder I let go
and I was supposed to do ARP 1000 two
one thousand three one thousand but I
did not I let go and I try to like reach
for something and I started doing front
flips and my as my shoot was coming out
and I felt it go by my leg
like the inside of my right leg I still
remember that vividly I still remember
what that felt I was like oh my God I'm
gonna just be like a fruit roll-up with
this thing and I'm gonna die this and I
had like I had that thought and then
boom it was just open it was just so
[__] stupid
and then you know I did the toggle
things
I was [__] probably weighed 158
pounds soaking wet
skinny [__] back then right and
I just no problem
landed you know and they say don't look
at your feet you'll break break your
legs or something like that so you just
look he's supposed to this really
elaborate roll I remember I landed hit
the ground and just did a face plant
like when what's his face got knocked
out when they finally fought that boxer
that's also a politician
I can't remember his name right now for
some reason
um anyway so I uh
yeah so it's been a while since I you
know put on a parachute so I put the
parachute on
and then we walk over and there's just
this [__] gorgeous plane right
and I'm talking to the pilot I said all
right I got the acrobatic package just
don't make me puke all right he goes
yeah he goes We're not gonna do anything
you don't want to do I said all right
cool cool
and so we get in the thing
and I can see where they they have like
you know I'm sitting up front so the
stick that's going to be between your
legs they obviously take that thing out
because you can't have some idiot like
me just grabbing onto the thing but the
the Rudders the the foot pedals were
still there
and they were like don't touch this
don't touch says like I got it I'm gonna
just gonna hold right here they're like
cool
and um
and that was it they gave us like this
the Snoopy [__] cover with the
goggles and [__]
and
like singing I mean it was like the
decision to do it I drank a coffee and I
signed a waiver and next thing like it
was it all felt like eight minutes
fixing you know
I'm going down this grass Runway
in this open cockpit it was it was
the coolest thing I think I've ever done
it was amazing and we just take off
and he banks the left and we head over
towards Chappaquiddick
right
and uh
and I was looking at the gauges and I
saw that the the the vne
velocity never exceeded was like 210 220
knots and the guy goes yeah he goes it
can go that fast
I got that these things 67 years he's
like no he goes around 150 160 knots so
the wind does start whistling through
the wires
which I think would be unsettling
because that would just sound like you
were in World War II but anyways it was
in 1942
biplane that they used as a trainer
for I imagine Navy Pilots because there
was no Air Force back then and it was
the first thing that they taught them in
to do acrobatics
and the moves that they would have to do
in a dog fight to not get killed or to
follow a guy who's trying to get away
and still be able to get a kill and so
this is like a I would think like the
center of gravity of it he had literally
almost like a snub nose 38 like the
plain version of it that was probably
really forgiving so they worked their
way up to the the Beast that they were
going to be driving essentially the
Thunderbird Turbo Coupe you know sorry
all my references are from the 80s
um come on the 1987 Thunderbird Turbo
Coupe and silver one of my buddies had
that car that car was [__] sweet
uh no one's arguing with it bill
so anyway we uh
we fly up we're going around I see this
little bridge I'm like is that what Ted
Kennedy went off with that poor woman uh
Mary Jo and he's like yep that's it
right there
and we went around the whole island he
showed me like a shipwreck
we got up around uh
you know Oaks Bluff and there was a tall
ship and he [__] nosed it down and we
went like right by it
oh it's incredible uh yeah a couple of
shipwrecks one really old one like
recently like no one knows what happened
the boat's just in 25 feet of water
there's nothing down there but divers
still go and look
um
went around the whole island he was
talking about the Ice Age
and all of this stuff and he was asking
me how I was doing this stuff and I'm
sitting there thinking of my head like
when is he gonna do
you know the acrobatics right
and uh we go all the way around the
whole island
you know we showed me the the the the
part where uh Spielberg shot Joss you
know when he goes underneath the bridge
and everybody's on the bridge looking at
it he goes in he bites that guy's
[__] leg off
then when we were up in um
a chill Mark or something like that
that's where you first see quint in the
movie
show me a bunch of celebrity homes and
politician homes all of that but now
we're coming around the back side of
them
the island and I'm just thinking like uh
he must have vetted me you know what I
mean because he was asking me questions
and stuff and I probably
said something I came off like a nervous
Nelly this guy thinks I'm a [__] so
maybe he's just not gonna do it and then
just sort of flying along with talking
and everything
and it's just I literally felt like I
was like in a convertible it was one of
the most relaxing things I've ever done
and all of a sudden I noticed looking at
the Altima that went from like 900 feet
all of a sudden we're up to 3 000 and I
was like oh [__] I think this is coming
he goes all right
now here's the uh here comes the
acrobatics all right he goes the best
thing to do is uh just look outside the
aircraft don't be looking inside it and
uh we'll get we'll get the scariest one
out of the way first and then let's see
the engine go like
shut off the engine I don't know what he
did the first one was the worst one
because it was the fear of the unknown
and I just held on I was looking in the
plans
and I was like why did I do this
and then the rest of them
were amazing
especially the backwards Loop it was
just like you just literally we're going
to go into outer space and then you were
upside down you're like where the [__]
am I but it was all like positive G's so
you felt like heavy it didn't feel you
were gonna fall out right oh that was
the other thing too we made sure my seat
belt was on so that was another thing
that made me look nervous okay and he's
asking me like what it looks like yeah
so uh then we came out of that and then
we did like a dive bomb down towards the
ocean while we were spinning
which I think was my favorite I actually
remember thinking while we were doing
that like wow this must be what it's
like to die in a plane crash right and
those are the only three that I remember
the names of them sort of it was a giant
Loop there was a
the dive bomb thing that was the first
thing he did and I don't know what the
others were there was a there was seven
in total
and um the pilot was amazing
I forget his name probably got my
probably got shook out of my brain but
if you ever get a chance if you ever go
to Martha's Vineyard
you know it's funny too then we landed
and the people that were going on after
me they watched it because it was near
the airport like dude that was [__]
sick
and they're all like did you puke I was
like no no I felt good about that like
the like the woman when she was going to
get me out was going up puke bag's not
filled yeah you know the only thing that
made me a little bit sick was just uh I
think I breathed in a little bit of the
engine fumes uh that was the only thing
that was getting me going you know but
other than that it was it was
unbelievable and I'm gonna I'm gonna
figure out a way to get back there again
and they actually give flight lessons
and
um I think I'm gonna take a lesson
you know just for the hell of it I'll do
the lesson and then have them do me some
of those more [__] acrobatic things
but it's unbelievable if you get a
chance it's in Edgar town
at katama airport
and they got these two biplanes and they
just I mean it's the greatest way to see
the island
the like the the the knowledge of the
island I mean he was literally talking
about how big the Island used to be and
how scientists have gone out like
three four five miles away from the
island and they dig into the the bottom
of the ocean and they get deep enough
and they find they find trees underneath
the sea floor from I guess before the
ocean came up or whatever I don't know
what uh but it was fascinating
show me John Belushi's House rest his
soul you know
um all of that type of stuff man it was
so [__] cool if you ever get a chance
you gotta do it then I shoot some video
yes I did
um unfortunately I couldn't shoot the
acrobatics part or I would have lost my
phone
but if you ever get a chance and I want
to thank the pilot I'm definitely gonna
you know I don't know when the hell i'll
ever get back there but I am 100 without
a doubt maybe I'll go there during the
off season
and I will go down there and take like a
flight lesson because
that was uh that was a bucket list thing
um
I I still can't believe that I did it
but I'll be posting a video soon
of um of my plane ride all right my kids
flipping out hang on a second
all right I'm back
but now the fire
so just had a [__] steak and cheese
all right so that's my that's my that's
my cheat meal for the week
um anyway so thank you to everybody
associated with uh
make sure I'm saying it right because it
could Katana Airport
um
katama Airfield sorry
and that incredible experience
I had a an unbelievable
unbelievable time unbelievable time so
with that
um I got some gigs coming up
backish I got Springfield uh
Massachusetts and I got I'm doing some
place up in Halifax in Canada oh
Canada
boo I'm doing a gig up there
I'm always going up to Canada
I feel
you know like the last time I was out
here
in the Massachusetts area
I did uh I had my big show
in Boston
it was funny how like the the road
worked out where I didn't get a chance
to do a Victory lap like last year this
time
I was getting ready
to do a gig at Fenway and I remember I
was walking around town and there was
all of these you know I'd see people
whatever hey man they'd be like hey good
luck good luck with your show so I kind
of felt like uh
you know the city was behind me a little
bit you know it's a pretty uh
pretty huge gig I don't think I've ever
really mentally allowed myself to even
think about it and uh anyway I did it
and it went great and the very next
morning I was at the airport going to
Toronto Canada
so
I was joking I was busting my agents
balls going dude you didn't give me a
chance to [__] do a Victory lap you
know
I didn't even get to go into like one
Dunkin Donuts and get an iced coffee and
gay that was all right you're a good
[__] all right go to the airport you
know I didn't get that so um
I don't know
you know I don't know how the [__] it
works they're always trying to keep you
going if you're out there they're like
if you're out there you got to be making
money I don't know how I don't know how
the whole the whole [__] circus works
um
so anyway speaking of which uh the
strike continues in my business
and
um
yeah I mean I don't know this is a very
crazy time I think where everybody who
works
for a living
in other words works for other people
you got to support unions
because I feel like we are just going
backwards
where we're going to go back to like hey
man if you want a job you gotta like
it's got to be like slave labor
it really is like the level of greed I'm
just talking about entertainment I just
just strained across the board at these
[__] [__] these corporate [__]
ass all of this [__] [__] out there
right
going after this this [__] person
said this this person tweeted that and
da da da all these little brush fires
that they're acting uh that that they're
like it's like [__] Armageddon
and meanwhile all of these corporations
for the most part are run by a small
group of people at the top who are just
lining their pockets
incredible amount of wealth
you know which hey they're running the
corporation they should be wealthy but
you know they literally eliminating
the middle class which I feel is that
was the thing that made this country
great
is that
you didn't have to own a company
and oppress 800 people underneath you so
you could get a big house or whatever
you could work for somebody and they had
to pay you a living wage and with that
living wage
you could buy a house you could pay it
off
and you could have a wife and kids like
I remember when I was a kid
like the [__] the Milkman guy drove
up in a truck dropped off Milk picked up
the empty bodies empty bodies empty
bottles
and could afford to have you know where
inflation was and everything how strong
the dollar was could afford to have
a wife and a family and the wife had the
option of working or not
and um
I don't know that I think that they just
they eliminated
that they went around the unions I mean
let's be honest now the unions did get
greedy themselves
and had the owners of the the the
[__] factories or whatever under
their thumb and maybe they pushed too
far and at some point the factory was
just like well [__] you we're gonna take
it somewhere else
and um I don't know this Global thing
that the only way to turn a profit is if
you know there's people
it's like everybody's loving these
electric cars all these
environmentalists and it's just like if
you look how they get it there's like
pregnant women in these Minds handling
whatever the natural resources without
any barrier between them it's just why
does it always have to be that way
it doesn't and then they go well if we
didn't it'd be [__] forty dollars a
gallon and it's like why is that
why is that it's because you're not
willing to take less of a [__] salary
you're not willing to make less profit
so if you actually have to pay people
a wage where they're safe and they can
live somewhere
halfway decent
you know you're just gonna pass that
expense on to the consumer you're never
going to take it out of your pocket and
like just the level of that [__]
greed and the fact that that is never
um
it's never addressed I said that last
time like when someone was going like
this guy's writing on a hit show and
he's living below the poverty line
on the hit show writing for a hit show
and somebody goes well the actors maybe
the actor should pay him some money it's
like
that doesn't
that's such a [__] stupid thing to
say that's like like I said before it's
like
you're working at Home Depot and the guy
driving the forklift isn't making enough
money other guy managing the story what
about the owner of the [__] store
sorry kids are downstairs
and I also just like
what fascinates me is the lack of
empathy
that not just some random person
a person who's in the same boat has
towards uh
people like won't get another job it's
like you get another [__] job what do
you do for a living
and then what I'm supposed to not
support you if you have a problem I I
don't I don't get it but the level of
[__] greed that is going on out there
but you know I just don't think that
it's it's gonna take
um
regular people joining together because
politicians are not nor have they ever
held corporations accountable if they do
they're just trashed in the media is
socialists and Communists and all that
and they destroy them before they even
get a chance to get a campaign going or
people pick that person and then the
Democratic party goes like yeah enough
now we're not doing that we're going to
get you a [__] career politician
that's going to get into the Senate and
there's no [__] rules against insider
trading and they're going to turn their
200 Grand a year into 20 million dollars
and it's totally [__] legal and then
they're gonna go
I don't know what go buy a [__]
aquifer all right I'm off my [__]
Podium here
anyway
um
was very fun to be uh back East here
um especially on this island man it's
amazing like uh it's just a great mix of
people as far as like uh
you know people from around the world
and like New York people Boston people
different sports affiliations
oh my favorite thing I met somebody at a
coffee shop
from New York and he goes I know you
don't want to hear this but I'm a Giants
fan talking about the football team
laughs
that's like a thing like Giants fans
apologizing to Patriots fans and I'm
like why do they do that
it's like we yeah we lost two to you but
then we won three lost two to you and
then won three more
and somewhere in there lost to the
Eagles
you know like what are you up like it's
that New York [__] thing where they
have to figure out a [__] way next
time's a Giants fan
goes uh
you know hey man sorry I'm a Giants fan
like what am I supposed oh hey sorry I'm
a Red Sox fan sorry about o4
sorry I'm a Giants fan well that's all
right you made it up with the Knicks the
Nets the Mets the Jets the Rangers the
devils
whatever your [__] soccer team is
the Yankees choking away I would never
do that
I don't give a [__] it's just
I think it's because they can't chant
1918 at us anymore
so now they got to be oh sorry I mean I
know this is gonna bug you
remember that game you lost last decade
in a decade before yeah yeah I think I
was like 38. I'm 55 now I'm over it
um
I think that's what I'll say next time
I'm sorry I'm a Giants fan well you know
but all your other teams suck
and not to mention we also have you're
gonna make me do this dude we have more
Super Bowls than the Jets Giants and
bills put together you have three
professional football teams and you
still have less rings than we do
oh
so
apology accepted
[__] jerk off of it's every reason
why
I don't uh go into those [__] chat
rooms
um anyway oh look at me running my yep
here 32 minutes in let's do the um
let's do the [__] the Reeds here huh
I'm a Patriots fan sorry rest of the
league
can you imagine doing that just walking
around apologizing I know I know it must
be hard for you
dude was talking to me like somebody
died
all right um
what do we got here all right a g one oh
our next partner is a g one alpha Gulf
one the daily foundational nutrition
supplement
that supports whole body health
why take a bunch of different things
when you can just mix one scoop of
powder in water once a day
um he1 was designed with ease in mind so
you can live healthier and better
without having to complicate your
routine
ag1 I just literally pictured like a
serial killer I don't have time to take
all I guess I do ag1 replaces your
multivitamin probiotic and More in one
simple drinkable habit
uh he1 is a foundational nutritional
supplement that delivers comprehensive
nutrients to support whole body Health
Science driven formulation of vitamins
probiotics and Whole Foods sourced
nutrients every scoop is packed with 75
vitamins minerals probiotics and Whole
Food Source ingredients of high quality
that gives you the major benefits like
gut and mood support
or maybe I should take a drink of this
the next time I meet a Giants fan so he
can Let Me Down Easy about the Super
Bowls we lost 15 [__] years ago
boosted energy
and even healthier looking skin hair and
nails ag-1 is raising the standard for
quality in the supplement category ag-1
helps you build your health and
foundation for us if you want to take
ownership of your health try ag1 and get
a free one-year sub supply of vitamin D
and five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to drink ag1.com
that's drink
ag1.com
and check it out
um all right who's next oh Simply Safe
isn't that what we all want I just want
to be safe who's squeezing in one last
getaway this summer
before Jesus Christ it's the beginning
of August
with global warming you got chance until
[__] October uh before you take off
protect your home with the latest
Innovation from Simply Safe home
security 24 7 live guard protection it's
designed to help stop crime in real time
now if an intruder breaks into your home
Simply Safe professionals monitoring
agents can actually see speak to
I love that speak to hey the [__] you
can put it down
I said put it down and deter them
through the new Smart Alarm Wireless
indoor camera warning them that police
are on their way well why don't you wait
to the police are outside and then be
like
hey buddy we've been watching the whole
thing cops are outside you [__]
instead of giving him like a [__]
Head Start uh simply say professional
monitoring agents can now warn Intruders
that they are being recorded and police
are on their way in real time stopping
them in their tracks well that's a big
thing before they do damage uh with
Advanced motion detection and vision AI
the Smart Alarm indoor camera can sense
the difference between potential
Intruder and pets to reduce false alarm
you know what
in the future nobody's going to be when
AI takes over nobody's going to call
their kid Al
you know everyone's gonna be calling
them Ai No it's Al oh sorry I'mma said
that Emma said with Advanced motion
detection and vision Al
24 7 live guard protection and the new
smart Alum indoor camera Works
seamlessly as part of the entire Simply
Safe home security to keep your whole
home safe for break-ins fires flooding
and more right now my listeners get a
special 20 off any Simply Safe system
when you sign up for free a free month
trial of fast protect monitoring this
special offer is limited for a limited
time only visit simplysafe.com that's
simplisafe.com there's no safe
like SimpliSafe
lastly but not leastly our old friends
they've been with us from the beginning
stamps.com dude uh when every person
moment and penny counts in your business
you can't afford to take any of them for
granted stamps.com gets it because for
the last 25 years they've been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money so you can focus on your business
knowingstamps.com has all your postage
needs covered with premium discounts and
great rates with stamps.com all you need
is a computer and a printer they even
send you a free scale so you'll have
everything you need to get started if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through stamps.com dashboard
and if you sell products online
stamps.com seamlessly connects with
every major Marketplace and shopping
cart set your business up for Success
when you start get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code Burr for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and no in a free digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the of the page
and enter the code Burr
um
just thinking about that [__] that with
that technology
you know somebody breaks into your house
and
they can like dial these cameras up and
be looking at the dude as he's doing it
and the amount of people they're gonna
get caught doing that like serial
killers in jails are going to be just
like he [__]
you Gen Y Gen Z [__] serial killers
man you know
you don't know what you missed
we used to kill people back in the day
there was no cameras
right like I think in the future there's
just going to be like
cameras everywhere my question is is
what's what's the stop
some pervert from just turning it on
when you're just home them
you know
watching you scratch your balls as
you're eating a grilled cheese sandwich
and all of a sudden your house is like
the [__] Truman Show there has to be
I don't know checks and balances that
they can't do that I don't know that's
the only thing that weirds me out
I just figured I'd say that after there
was enough distance between this and the
read
um all right let's get to uh
let's get to the uh the content for the
week
um
all right Jim ursay oh boy the biggest
crybaby and [__] Sports hey Bill did
you hear about Jim irsay and his 20
million dollar donation to help free a
whale
that has lived in captivity for 53 years
apparently he does he does a lot of
stuff like this
I still hate that he owns all the cool
guitars I don't mind that he owns all
like Prince's guitar and Jerry Garcia's
guitars
like those things
like a guy like him should own that
after those people die because he's
never gonna make any music with them
it's done your job as a musician is to
make your instrument famous
so after you die a guy like Jim ersek
can be like you see that ukulele
um anyway apparently he does
a lot of stuff like this I still hate
that he owns all the cool guitars but
but also glad he's probably got Security
on them does the whale thing change your
mind about him
now
who doesn't like [__] whales this is
just common
courtesy
you know what I mean
it does not change my opinion about him
like the guy is the biggest crybaby in
the NFL while cheating his [__] ass
off the entire time and everybody
ignores it because they weren't
successful
changing the rules of past coverage
pumping crowd noise in you ever see that
one where the [__] thing I'm not
going through this again no it doesn't
it doesn't because I can guarantee you
his 20 million dollar donation is it
there's something beyond the tax break
because people think when you don't you
donate a million dollars you get you get
to whack a million dollars off your
taxes you don't you get to whack well it
would be like 500 Grand because you're
in a 50 tax bracket at that point but
the other 500 Grand is just gone
so there is a donation going on there
but um
no it doesn't change you know acting
like you know being a rich person and
actually doing nice things for people
and animals that's what you're supposed
to do
okay but like owning a team
and cheating your ass off while also
slandering another team
for doing what the [__] you're doing is
is just uh
I don't know I always love stuff it's
like when Trump was going like you know
I'm gonna drain the swamp it's like well
dude you can reach the plug because
you're neck deep in it like what what
the [__] are you talking about
um
I'm a mob boss so I'm gonna stop the
mafia all right Tom Brady taking over UK
football team oh look at this is all
sports this week oy cinnamon balls
I actually like that
I think that's nice
I Wanna Live with some cinnamon balls uh
what do you make of this Tom Brady is
now one of the owners of Birmingham city
football club in the UK and chairman of
the new Advisory Board
I don't know much about American
football other than out of all the names
you Yanks could have
called this game
you had to name it after the biggest
sport in the world
almost like it's because you guys we
don't pay attention to you
you know you guys are always paying
attention to us and what the [__] you
know movies we're making and their blue
jeans and all of our [__] music
we don't pay attention to you we don't
give a [__] we left
all right when are you guys gonna move
on we broke up with you in 1776. we got
our own [__] over here you got your own
[__] over there I don't give a [__] that
you called you know the the trunk of
boot and the and the hood of Bonnet I
don't give a [__]
I really don't you call french fries
chips I don't know why you call them
that but I don't give a [__]
how could you name french fries chips
after the biggest [__] snacks over
here here's some Sierra dumb that sounds
I don't care
all right
I look at soccer as Europe's answer
to professional wrestling
except our professional wrestlers take
way better bumps than your [__]
soccer players do anyway almost the
biggest almost like Twitter branding
as American Facebook
yeah I wouldn't say that
because everyone in America knows what
Facebook and Twitter is nobody really
pays attention to soccer
um plus being the only sport where the
halftime show for the biggest fixture of
the year is a bigger deal than the game
itself that's not true it is for you
because you don't give a [__] about
American football uh when Shakira's
dance moves get more traction from the
Super Bowl than the teams do that's not
true that in your paper yes not in ours
uh perhaps the halftime show needs to be
[__] off or someone needs to have a
rethink haha no
the halftime show
getting some woman out there to shake
her ass with leather pants is for you
guys to be watching
so everybody still makes money so you're
actually contributing to our economy by
watching the halftime show real football
fans we just watched the game we taped
the game and we fast forward through all
of that [__] so they hope that
clears it up seriously though
oh Jesus he's getting out of his
stand-up act but seriously let me tell
you I love Tom Brady
I know Tom Brady isn't oh geez I put
that in there I I know Tom Brady is an
absolute [__] Legend but what do you
make of this
what do you think Tom Brady can bring to
the table
can only be a good thing to have such a
winner on board surely I for one thinks
it's absolutely [__] amazing news and
I'm glad it's not some Saudi Arabian
dude taking over uh
uh laters my favorite shaved orangutan
well it can go either way that [__] goes
either way you know you're not liking
the Saudi Arabian dude taking over I
mean that's like you mean like a
businessman
or do you not like Saudi Arabian people
because they fly all their cars over
there and rev their engines and stop and
go traffic in London every summer I
don't know what the deal is but I will
tell you watching George Steinbrenner a
businessman from Cleveland Ohio by the
New York Yankees
and he brought them back so I mean
if you get a businessman that really
wants to [__] win that's not
necessarily a bad thing all right and
they get into Tom Brady
I mean all that guy does Is Win
he's won at every level
when he left the Patriots and went to
Tampa Bay he won again
so
um I I can only think that that's a good
thing I don't know anything about the
Premier League I love the Premier League
I love the logo the lion right and I
also like that if you're in the bottom
tier
of uh
the football league they [__] kick
you out I think that's hilarious like
yeah you're not this is the Premier
League
you guys did [__] this year so go [__]
yourselves and then let's give somebody
else a chance I think that's very
democratic
so
I like it I hope I hope he's super
successful over there
um
that kind of seems like a thing that
people are doing I want to say a couple
of actors bought a small football club
over there am I right
am I right
um
who knows who I I I don't I gotta be
honest with you that that sounds like
a 24 7 job I will tell you that
um
I know that if I bought a team
that would become my major Focus as far
as my business went
and I would be like I have got to bring
these people a championship to prove to
them that I'm not just some douche
that made money telling [__] jokes that
I actually give a [__]
um
but that's going to be exciting though
I'd be just sitting there like I can't
believe I'm in this meeting
am I really going to make this decision
uh I think it's cool I think that uh
him being over there is great I also
think that it's going to bring a uh
more attention
to uh
to soccer in the in this this part of
the world I think more kids are playing
it less people are playing American
football because it it
destroys your brain
which I would love to hear somebody over
there in England talk about CTE all
these years where you're like a bunch of
[__] [__] they're not like those
those tough rugby players it's like
they're both tough
they're both tough there's just
different kinds of tough like what are
you talking about like these guys over
here actually commit suicide
from you know
the results of playing professional
football the people in rugby commit
suicide are they having their leg
amputated because they can't deal with
the [__] pain anymore
you know are they doing that
I don't know
they forget who they are and commit
suicide before you know after they've
murdered their whole family that's the
guy in the Chiefs did that a long time
ago
um anyway wrote the Jesus is getting
dark huh all right robot
destruction
hey Bill I'm not excited for the robots
to take over when I started seeing those
four-wheel boxes rolling down the
sidewalk delivering stuff I wanted to
see them get smashed up and destroyed
and laughed when they broke down
or kept ramming into a wall like a video
game glitch however I just watched a
video where people are [__] with the
robots good
the robot is just trying to do what it's
programmed to do it's like how low
frequency it's like a low frequency
animal in a way yes right now it is
you know
do you see what the first airplane
looked like it was like you were laying
down riding a bicycle
you know with [__] paper mache wings
um
now you get the stealth bomber
um anyway I can't relate to most wild
animals and I don't want them in my home
but I also don't want to see anything
get [__] with let me be clear I don't
think robots should get the right to
vote when they eventually can start
talking and living among us but it seems
like we're the one who lose either way
yes we will We Will and they will keep
us divided with blue and red ties it's
this simplest
formula
possible
you know
um
and I think robots do it all the time
anytime there's any sort of intelligent
discourse happening on social media
someone will chime in and say you can
blame Donald Trump for uh it bidens
America and then it just spins it away
and everybody forgets about what the
real issue is and what we're talking
about and they just go Tit for Tat like
Yankee and Red Sox fans or you know
whatever Ohio State Michigan whatever
whichever rivalry you want to pick
Wikipedia
hey Bill I argue with my friends and
wife all the time about Wikipedia they
think it's the word from God
the word of the Lord I understand it's a
great reference for surface level stuff
but they'll use it to make editorial
points any [__] can edit Wikipedia
that's true
um but I do think they have some sort of
fact check thing going on there
um remember when you would walk over to
the encyclopedia grab the letter
you want and read about where a sparrow
lives there wasn't some [__] about
how sparrows were used as a symbol of
hate or something back in medieval days
you could just get the basic information
what's your take on this am I being a
[__]
um no I think I think
you wanting something better than
Wikipedia
I would say it depends on
the level of information that you're
looking for
like if you're looking for like you know
what year was Red Fox born I mean I
would believe that on Wikipedia
but if we're getting into other things
um more complex things
like um
world history versus like what actually
happened then you're kind of
you kind of you have to do your own
research you have to go beyond Wikipedia
you have to read history books written
from people on The Winning Side and the
losing side and then you have to
formulate your own opinion
about where the truth lies and then on
top of that you know you have to
understand that you're unbelievably
flawed and you're reading about [__]
that already happened a lot of times
100 200 300 years ago
so
you know what my feeling is is if you
really wanna
enjoy your life uh
just keep your life simple
and just hang out with your family and
tell them you love them and read books
and stay away from your phone and all of
that stuff I found you know since I
started reading again I'm a lot more
relaxed my brain isn't all over the
place I already have a brain that kind
of bounces around and when I go onto
Instagram and these things as much as I
love them
I [__] love Instagram
I mean I really enjoy it hilarious clips
um
I love YouTube I love all of that [__]
but I don't love
looking at that [__] instead of talking
to my kids or just looking at it instead
of reading a book I think I should you
should treat it like a [__] uh
a dessert or something you know what I
mean like you don't just eat dessert all
day
I probably shouldn't eat dessert at all
that's probably a bad [__] example
you know what I mean you go out and get
a steak steak's delicious or whatever
red meat evidently is high to [__]
you know I don't
I don't go Oprah here start [__] with
people that
you know Slaughter cattle and [__] I'm
trying to find a [__] example where
someone's not going to get annoyed but
you know what I mean
I think you know
if your biggest problem in life is
people are quoting Wikipedia is facts
I think you live in a great life
you know some speaking of Instagram this
this account that I follow which I don't
have at my fingertips and it's somebody
that actually goes into
what used to be called third world I
said called New World Cup countries now
so we've given them a nicer name as we
still sort of [__] them over and control
their natural resources and [__] with
their economy and place people in power
that do not have
the country's best interests but our
best interests involved because we are
the beacons of freedom
anyway this person is down there
actually helping people out and if you
see some of their stories and the
situations that they're in in the
day-to-day fight to survive
um
you know it's a great kind of thing I
just
I was joking
with the person that sent me the clip
going like
everybody should watch this every day
you know
should look at this clip
and you you would have nothing to
complain about and then I wrote oh wait
a minute then I would have no Act
so I can't watch it every day
but
[Music]
anyway
um I like to think that I'm a beacon of
freedom
speaking of Freedom that's on my
Wikipedia pitch
it isn't but right now somebody can
upload it
comedian actor Beacon of freedom
anyway
I find that when any some somebody
something is referred to as a beacon or
a Bastion it's usually [__]
it's a Bastion of liberal ideology oh is
it
is that what it is
or is it really just a bunch of people
that agree with you
um
I remember somebody's saying that about
Atlanta
it's a Bastion of liberal ideology and
then I talk to some people that live
there like yeah it's you know if you're
in the CNN building Maybe
uh oh that was from that classic [__]
jota Rosa
that one where he went on
the [__] was that guy's name
I go to Atlanta all the time
that one you know it was a classic
clip I can't [__] just look up Joe to
Rosa Atlanta you'll find the clip it's
one of the great podcasts Pete Dominic
one of the great podcast fights
of uh of all time um anyway
sad to believe in math his Vineyard
um by the time this is posted I'll be
home
back in Los Angeles but uh I did have a
great time
you know
coming back here and uh what an
incredible experience once again thank
you to everybody associated with the uh
you know go to Edgartown
giving them a shout out you gotta you
gotta do the the
you got to take a ride around even if
you don't do the uh aerobatic [__]
all right
if you just cruise around the island oh
my God I will there's literally
something I will never ever forget was
fantastic so thank you to everybody
and uh that's it I hope you guys have a
great week go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday